[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel ramsy
Personality YouTube star of The George
camel show is my co-host today it is
book launch week for George his new book
Breaking Free from broke is on the
shelves it came out officially yesterday
The Ultimate Guide to more money and
less stress and George goes through with
great research showing the villains that
are out there and the people that are
trying to uh keep you down they're the
man with the thumb on your neck and you
got the thumb off their neck absolutely
and it's been encouraging to see the
feedback Dave H one lady this was a
great message I got yesterday I've been
reading the e book we've been paying off
the credit card in full monthly for
years but your chapter on how predatory
the credit card companies are has
changed that we've switched to debit
cards only I felt like I needed a shower
after reading the stats on who's paying
interest and who's getting rewards I
don't want to be a part of that system
anymore wow that's what I was hoping for
a little social movement there we are
starting a movement where people are
going these companies are not my friend
and uh their marketing is so slick I
mean how many people brag about their
credit card rewards and how much they
love their sentimental security blanky
and so that's just one of the many traps
I uncover and it's been great to see
that kind of feedback yeah you're
getting getting people to get rid of
their little plastic plastic blanky yeah
and you've been doing it for years Dave
getting them riled up with with anger I
just do it with snark we have different
methodologies there snark is just
passive aggressive anger that's right
open phones atle
88255 225 as we talk to you Micah is in
Washington DC hey hi Michael what's
up hey Dave hey George thanks for taking
my call sure what's up hey so a little
bit about me I'm uh 24 I'm currently
debt free um I make $80,000 a year I am
currently maxing out my 401k and
Ira I want to buy a car that cost
$30,000 um however I don't want to get
rid of my current car it would just be a
you know a play car it's it's a sports
car my question is is I have 30,000 in
cash that I'm prepared to pay for this
car um not sure if it's better to put
this in a different sort of Investment
Portfolio or if it would be okay you
know to to splurge and buy this car oh I
see I thought you were calling the car
an investment my face was turning inside
out okay um so what's the car I'm a car
guy I love
gears so it's a Nissan 370Z a sweet nice
car okay and what your
model uh 2019 okay all right cool and
what's the car you're currently driving
worth um it's
$133,000 okay all right um what's your
income
trajectory uh when would you be making
90 uh
potentially maybe five years from now
whoa so I'm you're gonna get $10,000
raise over five
years uh well I'm I'm I'm projecting a
promotion and then um how the military
works when I move oh you're in the
military correct okay now I understand
okay yeah that would be more reasonable
in the military most people are going to
make a lot more in five years than a
$10,000 race I'm just tell that's why I
went right right yeah
okay well I mean here's the
thing I love cars okay I drove here
today in my Raptor I I I love big
engines uh I like things that make noise
I'm redneck I want a loud Muffler um all
that right uh but the stupid things go
down in
value Like a Rock that's where Chevy got
that like a rock okay they go down in
value and that includes that sweet
Nissan you're talking about and that
includes my sweet Raptor they go down in
value so if you're going to build wealth
you have to keep as small an amount and
as possible going into things that go
down in value so consequently we find
millionaires driving very conservative
used
cars until they until they've got you
know substantial money um and the one of
the guidelines that George that we've
developed here is to not have more than
half your annual income tied up in
things that have Motors and wheels so
adding up all of your little toys with
motors and
wheels uh do does it add up to more than
half your annual income because if it
does you probably got too much in things
going down in value while you're trying
to build wealth does that make sense to
you Ma
mathematically yeah yes like I mean it'd
be like $45,000 total yeah and you make
80 and so you're over
half yeah okay so um sweet car sweet car
and you got the cash if you do it you
can do it I mean you can afford it
obviously but the warning is that you're
putting money in the wrong places if you
want to be
wealthy got it I mean the way you know
someone's going to stay middle class is
when they have two very ni cars that are
obvious 56 $700 payments sitting in
front of a middle class
house exactly 100% those people are
going to stay middle class until they
break that habit it's just a it's a huge
indicator yeah and the other thing to
think about Micah is you got another set
of insurance premiums to pay more
maintenance and repair and so right now
as you're in the military I don't know
how much driving you're doing on these
vehicles but I would consider those cuz
it is a toy and so this is not going to
crush you if you do it but we're just
saying it may not be the time yeah I
I as much as I completely grasp what
you're doing and I I and you know that's
a great car I as the guy on the radio
that tells you to do things to become
wealthy I'm going to tell you don't do
it I'm going to tell you wait a later
when you've got more money and you're in
a better financial position to do it
you've got the money to pay cash if you
do it's not going to bankrupt you that
is not what we're saying we're not being
melodramatic I just wanted when I went
broke when I was younger older slightly
older than you I I I made the decision
I'm going to do things that cause me not
to be broke anymore and I'm going to
identify what broke people do I'm not
going to do that I'm going to identify
what rich people do and I am going to do
that and you know what we discover Tom
Stanley found it first in 1992 when he
did did a book called Millionaire Next
Door we discovered it again when we did
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in North America
10,167 of them we interviewed we did not
find fancy cars it was Honda Toyota
four-year-old used cars nothing that's
going to turn heads at the stoplight
yeah if they're millionaires now if
you're a billionaire it's different you
can drive whatever you want to drive
right but a billion is a thousand
million it's a different thing scales
yeah millionaires don't have that they
don't have Jets millionaires don't have
seven cars uh millionaires don't you
know that millionaires just have some
money is all and and they have generally
speaking conservative but reasonable
Lifestyles and so we tell folks not to
buy a brand new car until you have a net
worth of of a million dollars if you do
have a car you should sell it if it
violates those things and or if you
can't get it and all your Consumer Debt
paid off within two years because of the
stupid car and so if you got like a
$50,000 car you make $60,000 a year you
need to sell it and you need to you know
get rid of this $1,100 pay payment and
just choking you to death it loses 60%
of the value in 5 years these new cars
it's brutal we went through a period of
time on this show about a decade ago
where the answer to every question was
sell the car sell the car it was the
sell the car show it was people would
call up and we'd go hey how you doing
sell the car that was it amputate the
next caller next caller amputate the
Tahoe that's right just don't tell
people to sell their horse Dave I
learned that the hard way oh yeah you
got you got really you got the horse
people George they got on George the
equestrian Community they're no fans of
mine estrian Community there we go no it
was the horse people this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our Health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
88255 225 will is in Atlanta hi Will how
are you good how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's
up um about two months ago my
grandmother passed away and um I
received about a $1.1 million
inheritance wow wow I'm sorry for your
loss and thrilled for your blessing what
a wonderful what a wonderful thing she
did that's amazing you're the only
grandkid no I'm one of two kids each of
you got
1.1 yes way to go
granny wow um but my question today was
how how do I make I'm 23 years
old um I was I was just calling to find
out how do I make the absolute most of
this so this is a little bit
intimidating to you yes
ex good that's a good sign that means
you're wise if you were having a woohoo
I hit the lottery moment it would mean
you're a child and so I'm glad you're a
little bit that's a great it should take
your breath away a little bit this kind
of fear is the beginning of wisdom so
way to go it's a good fear I don't want
you to be panicked or anxiety ridden or
anything like that but I do want you to
be aware I just got behind the wheel of
a car that is way more powerful than
anything I've ever driven and I need
some driving lessons that's what you're
aware of good for you so proud of you
good good good good good okay uh first
thing is keep that mindset second thing
is never put money in something you
don't
understand no matter who says to
including
me anywhere you read or hear to put
money in something and you can't tell
somebody else how it works in detail do
not put money in
it okay okay which means you might be
going a little bit slow at first because
it's money might just be sitting in a
bank account cuz that's that's what you
grasp right now
okay okay the the third thing is in the
Bible says in the multitude of council
there is safety money
people too many of them uh have a little
bit of arrogance in them and they want
to tell you what to do if you have a
money person an a financial advisor an
insurance person a real estate person an
estate planner that is telling you what
to do instead of teaching
you fire them and get another one you
want someone with the heart of a
teacher because it is not their job to
manage the money it's
yours your grandmother didn't leave it
to them she left it to you so it is your
job to sit with a mutual fund broker
with an advisor and learn and learn and
learn and learn and learn and and you're
doing that today you called us because I
want to learn what to do right that's
very good but always look for someone
with a heart of a teacher you cannot Al
offload the nervousness of this
responsibility by letting someone else
make your
decisions okay that makes sense yes if
you have to understand it and you have
to have people helping you that have the
heart of a teacher that helps you
understand it those two things work
together and then you're going to move
slow you just move at the speed of your
comfort at the speed of Peace when in
doubt
don't easy enough right that is very
easy yeah in other words when it your
stomach's moving up towards your throat
you wonder if this would make your
grandmother angry with you don't do
it which is your fourth thing each time
you make a decision with this money ask
yourself would this caus her sitting in
heaven to smile and be proud of her
grandson okay and if the answer is no
don't do it because this lady had some
this lady had some sense she left two
million bucks to her two
grandkids so I think we can use her as a
filter for our decision- making honoring
her Legacy honoring her memory causing
her to smile in heaven as our filter and
that's going to help you also does that
make sense to you yes it does okay so
there's no magic formula on what to do
with the money I put mine in growth
stock mutual funds and I pay cash for
real estate and I live 100% debt-free
and you probably already knew that yes I
do and George does the exact same thing
absolutely and when you look at this
money as a steward or a manager of it it
changes the filter and an easy way to do
this is filter it through the baby steps
number one but also filter it through
three buckets giving saving and spending
so you should give some of this and be
generous just like your grandma was you
should spend some of it and enjoy it and
you should invest probably the biggest
portion of this for the future what do
you
make um I currently make about 110,000 a
year okay so you don't need any of this
no yeah and so here's an interesting
thing if you put it in something like a
mutual fund and it makes 10% it'll
double every seven years so you're
you're you said you're
23 yes 23 years old yeah so it'll be 2.2
at 30
at 37 it'll be 4.4 at 44 it'll be
8.8 it'll be 16 million when you're
50 if you just don't touch it and invest
it and it makes
10% yeah currently
mindblowing I I I didn't get it like
wired to my bank account it just got
transferred into one of the financial
institutions that she was associated
with but currently it's split up about
350 50,000 is in personal stock choices
and CDs and then 750,000 is in a managed
stock account okay well I I don't play
single stocks so I probably wouldn't do
that because they're more risk but I
want you to get in there and start
figuring it out and again there's
nothing to panic about but feeling the
weight of this as a responsibility to
manage is a proper philosophical
spiritual stance for you if you do that
it'll cause your decision-making to be
different than just uh some little kid
who got some money and blows it all by
the time he's
26 yeah okay cuz you're not you're
already more manly than that I can tell
very wise yeah I'm very well done man I
I I assume I don't know if he said it
but no debt emergency fund in place
that's a good spot to be investing and
to buy a property with cash a reasonable
property enjoy some of it and then the
rest I'd be investing either in more
real estate if he's comfortable or just
putting it in some good mutual funds
just take your time just take your time
no rush yeah very very calm well good
question man so put good people in your
corner that have the heart of a teacher
they'll help you if you want to know
about the investing the way we do it and
the way I personally do it and get
someone with the heart of a teacher
click smartt Vestor at ramsy
solutions.com you'll find a smartvestor
pro or two or three in your area there
there are people that have the heart of
a teacher and know the way Ramsey does
it and they can walk you through that
and teach you what you're doing and and
they're they're going to move you out of
those single stocks I can tell you that
if once you understand you're going to
move you out of those single stocks Paul
is in Cleveland Ohio hey Paul welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi thanks for having me on how are
you better than I deserve what's
up um I'm trying to uh I recently
graduated from college I've got about
$220,000 in student loan debt um and
about 40,000 already invested um in my
retirement account split between a Roth
IRA and my company 401K what do you make
I'm trying to balance what's that what
do you
make I make about $660,000 a year okay
you're trying to balance what trying to
balance uh continuing to save for
retirement and getting ahead on that um
I'm 24 years old and um just making sure
that I also pay off the student loans so
OB I have a um got about $10,000 set
aside at an emergency fund and I'm just
trying to figure out what to do next
whether I should lump some pay down my
student loans or
um just keep saving for retirement since
the interest rates are a little bit
lower than what you expect to get out of
the stock
market well Paul I will talk to you like
I uh as if I went back in time because I
had more student loan debt than you and
I made less than you and so at 23 I was
$40,000 in student loan debt I wasn't
making any progress I was trying to play
the same game you are balancing this all
here's what you got to do Paradigm Shift
let's try a proven plan that means we're
going to take 9,000 from this emergency
fund pay down the debt that's going to
leave you with 11 left making 60 you're
going to knock that out quick pause
investing you'll be back to investing
probably in 6 months if you do it this
way yeah investing 15% don't balance
debt and investing get the debt cleared
and then go Whole Hog on the investing
that's what George is saying and he's
right this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Matthew is in Fort Worth
hey Matthew welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up so my wife and I we are uh
currently on baby step two and uh you
know being from Texas our biggest debt
is my truck besides our house um but I'm
kind of in a unique situation where my
company pays me mileage IRS mileage rate
and I do about 30,000 miles a year on
the truck which comes out to about
$20,000 a year in income and so it makes
a truck payment covers gas insurance and
all that I was just wondering um would
it be possible to keep the truck or
would you recommend getting something
downsizing and maybe pocketing some of
that mileage money put towards our other
debt whatever you drive
with those miles you're destroying its
value right yep correct so from a
business perspective if you were running
a
fleet you would buy the least expensive
vehicle that would get the job done
which would be less than your driving um
get the job done is reasonable Comfort
because you spend a lot of time in it
and uh reasonable reliability because
you have to get there
but that's that's the definition to get
the job done and certainly can do that
for half of what you're driving uh
because whatever you're driving you're
turning it into nothing in in you know
three years four years you put 120,000
miles in this
thing yeah correct and so now we've got
a you know highly depreciated vehicle
what did your truck cost when you bought
it uh right at 40,000 this a 2023 to way
of a Tacoma okay nice
truck plus interest
I owe about 35 on it currently yeah and
it'll be worth about five by the time
you're done with
it okay after putting on 200,000 miles
on there yeah I mean you're you're just
you're a road warrior you're whatever
you drive if you want to keep the Tacoma
and you've got the money and you make
enough money to pay this off and all
that kind of stuff I'd put it in the
driveway and I'd buy something else to
drive okay but because whatever you're
driving you need to just say out loud
I'm destroying it so we don't want to
destroy a nice car
yeah just kind of like my my thought was
by 120,000 miles you know the truck
should be paid off using the the expense
money and then you know it's a Toyota so
I'm hoping to get you know 300 get the
expense money whether you lose your butt
on the truck or not okay right y you
don't have to destroy a $440,000 truck
to get the expense money all right yeah
yeah yeah so I mean I I don't mind if
you keep the thing assuming the other
numbers add up and you can pay it off
you owe 35,000 what's your household
income uh about 175 okay how quickly can
you pay it off if you just lean into it
uh well we're we got about 13,000 credit
card debt right now and uh about 9,000
on the wife's car and then 35 on
this so you could be debt free in like a
year a little over a year yes that
that's the plan with the baby steps if
if I'm you I mean that's great truck
that's what Rachel's husband drives he's
got one they're great they're really
good trucks and and you like it
obviously because you're fighting to
keep it in the conversation
so but I don't really you make $175,000
a year you can drive you can own a
$35,000 Tundra it's okay but I would own
it and put it in the driveway I
personally wouldn't destroy it I mean
I've got the raptor r which is a super
expensive truck the 700 horsepower I'm
not putting those miles on that truck
okay I live8 miles from the office I
drive it to the office that's the only
place I drive it into the farm that's it
I'm not putting a bunch of miles on this
thing it's too expensive a vehicle to
destroy it with high mileage and um and
it gets crummy gas mileage with the 700
horsepower but but yeah but the it ain't
made for economy fuel it is not an
economy car you can't fit it in the
space and it doesn't qualify but yeah
same thing though I mean I can afford
the Ridiculousness of that and you can
afford this so I would say keep it and
get something else that you destroy the
value of yeah you make 175 pay off this
57 in no time and get you a little
commuter car and then get you a 105,000
truck and destroy it or whatever
whatever you want to drive in 12 months
you can do all of this yeah yeah you can
you're you're doing you're doing great
so I just want you to look at the whole
car thing different because you're
systematically destroying the vehicle uh
in value anyway I mean you're not the
the stupid tunder will probably run
300,000 miles if you take care of it so
you're not destroying it in that sense
CU a again great truck but uh but I I I
just wouldn't do that to that car uh you
know it doesn't make any sense and you
guys that are Road Warriors out there
and your company gives you a a car
allowance the car allowance is not
dependent upon you having a car
payment and the in his case the expense
you know they're giving him mileage and
stuff you get that if you drive a $5,000
paid for truck or $85,000 truck you get
the same exact mileage but people like
to justify the car want it's okay
because I get this no what you get it
anyway you're going to get the money
anyway pocket that 500 bucks instead of
sending it to A lender exactly don't you
keep it that'd be a great idea so way
good way to think about this stuff good
question sir we appreciate you joining
us open phones atle
5225 Adrien is in Detroit hi Adrien
welcome to the r Amy
show hi thanks for having me sure what's
up um so I am 33 and my husband is 35
and we are still working on baby step 2
so we have zero dollars in retirement
and it like keeps me up at night um I
don't know if we're too far behind
you're
303 I know but we still have 14,000 in
student loans I was bankrupt at
28 you're you're not too far
behind Okay Okay I'm glad you're a
little worried because it's going to
motivate you to not be uh a stupid
American
Consumer and you're going to get out of
debt and save money that's a good
motivation for the fear but I don't want
you anxiety ridden that that this is not
possible hopeless that this is not
possible you should retire with several
million dollars what do y'all make okay
um we make 97 with our like salary
full-time jobs but then we also do side
hustles and you have how much is student
loan
debt uh well we've paid off
158,000 in uh debt so far we have 14,000
left amazing how long that
take oh well we've on the Ramsey plan
for a little less than two years way to
go you off 158 in two
years yeah we sold our Tesla and yes
sell the horse sell the Tesla whatever
you got to do that's impressive so
you'll be out of this debt in a few
months it sounds like maybe six months
yeah that's our goal yeah our goal is to
be out of the debt and well hopefully
the next three months we're really going
to push it and then we got to save that
3 to six months but if you're if you're
34 years old and you save $155,000 a
year 15% of 100,000 from 34 to 65 I'm
doing this in my head but I think that's
probably going to be close to $10
million okay you're not you're not too
late you can
if I'm half wrong I think you'll be
okay okay okay thank you I do want you
to continue to follow the Ramsey plan
get your emergency fund in place and
start saving baby step 4 15%
right yeah and jump on jump on the
website at Ramsey and at Ramsey
Solutions and run the investment
calculator and it'll show you what
15,000 will be I did that in my head I
don't remember what it is but it's it's
but if you start with zero well in
excess of a million is probably between
5 and 10 yeah 30 years of working 15,000
Plus your income is going to go up over
time so think about that you're going to
be doing more than 15,000 a year over
the course of time with compound growth
over 30 years at you know 10% I mean
it's going to be mindling late you're
not too late you're in good shape if you
play through if you keep on the track
that you're on okay which is to work the
baby steps you're going to be a
multi-millionaire
okay okay thank you yeah you're but go
ahead and go ahead and do that math for
yourself and it helps you so a good a
good one to remember that's easy is age
25 to age 65 now she's going to be 35
before she starts but age 25 to age 65
$100 a month 1,200 a year that's nothing
$100 a month from 25 to 65 in a good
grow stock mutual funds 1,
176,000 wow sheer millionaire at return
and that's some weak savings rate and so
you think about the average income 15%
oh my goodness yeah it's unbelievably
weak yeah our you know if you follow our
stuff we're saving
15,000 not 1,200
that changes the numbers see see how I
did that that's how I did that this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys ramsy solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switch to netsuite it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll company
netw site can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day today up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situ situation
more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netu today and find out how
they can help you become the business
you want to be 5 or 30 years from now
and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you didn't know we
brought broadcast in Franklin Tennesseee
just a little bit south of Nashville
Tennessee It's a Wonderful Civil War era
Town historic and beautiful and point
and all that kind of stuff we're a
little bit South about an exit down and
uh folks come over to the Ramsey campus
all the time we've got a big Lobby to
welcome guests it includes a uh a whole
timeline the history of everything we've
done here uh places to take pictures and
remember the debt free stage is out
there there's free coffee free chocolate
chip cook
um and if it snows A4 of an inch in
Nashville people think that it's 92 in
deep and we're ready for a ski slope or
a blizzard and they go in freakout mode
so everything just shuts down like a
hard Frost shuts the town down okay and
so we usually have 50 to 200 folks
sitting out here watching the show we do
it live from 1 to4 Central every day
Monday through Friday and we always have
folks dropping by for the free C coffee
cookies and to watch the show uh and in
the afternoons we love having you thank
you for doing that uh because of the
snow we've got just a few folks out here
about 30 or 40 or so and a cat that runs
the lobby just announced uh to George
that we're going to give all of you guys
visiting Georgia's brand new book
Breaking Free from broke just as a gift
just to say thanks for coming out in the
snow the frost whatever this was and uh
that's our gift to you I said can we do
that she said yeah we we want it's
amazing let's do this we can do whatever
we want we're cat she's in charge that's
right so fun also also we had the Navy
Recruiting team dropped by uh they're
big sponsors of our high school
curriculum in a bunch of high schools
around America thank you to the Navy and
uh thank you to you guys we appreciate
you appreciate everything you do it's
absolutely incredible uh and it a lot of
students in America get the high school
curriculum because of you guys and we
appreciate you and of course we
appreciate your service so and if you
visit uh good note Dave that we actually
go out in the lobby twice an hour and
we'll greet people and sign books and
say hey so that's how we that's how we
found out about all this a minute ago
yeah we were all out you and I were out
there at the break getting book
getting so it's a it's a real fun way to
make a part of your Nashville trip it's
um it's it's it's not as cool as Disney
when the Mickey characters come out but
it's similar well some people are so
excited that I'm like you need to get
out more like this is too fun and Goofy
just went out saying who's who okay but
uh all right the ramsy show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for home services from repairs
and maintenance to Home Improvement
projects winter brings some challenges
for homeowners you need to check out
neighbor's helpful winter checklist
which you can download for free check it
out at neighborly
docomomo imately $200,000 in business
debt the majority being $150,000 small
business SBA loan that we personally
guaranteed the business failed about 5
months ago and we have left the business
to get regular jobs now the debt still
lingers and we're considering filing
Chapter 13 Bankruptcy soon but wondered
if there was a better way since this
debt is not from frivolous spending my
wife and I don't overspend in our
personal lives but this business debt is
in our name and destroying our credit
our mental state and our blood
pressure okay to start with chapter 13
is a payment
plan dude you're already on a payment
plan you you know you SBA loan gets paid
in full in Chapter 13 so you got 60
months and you're going to pay it off
for over five years in Chapter 13 so
filing chapter 13's useless you know if
you're already paying payments and you
can work your way through payments then
chapter 13 chapter 7 would clear the
loan uh except for the fact they
probably took a lean on your house and
they're probably going to take your
house if you do that and so
um I think you continue to work it
outside of bankruptcy Chapter 13 does is
no of no benefit to you except maybe
maybe getting the payment lower but
you're not going to get out of the debt
in a Chapter 13 and you're not going to
get out of the debt if they have a lean
on your house and most of the time the
SBA will take a lean on your house in
these situations so if they've got a
second on your house and there's big
equity in your house uh they're going to
take the
house uh in a you know you're either
going to pay them or they're going to
take the house a hundred cents on the
dollar
you know unless unless you negotiate
with them but CH but bankruptcy does not
make the SBA lean on your house go away
they if you have if it's there he didn't
say but that's a typical process for the
small business administration that's why
I hate SBA Loans I hate them because of
this exact situation right here so
um I I I instead would pretend like you
have a $200,000 student loan which is
also not bankrupt a by the way and
um I I I would just roll up my sleeves
and go bananas and take six jobs and get
your income up spending down get it get
it paid down as fast you can throw 50k
out of a year basic math says we can pay
this off in four years yeah if you can
pay 100 a year you're done with this in
two years and so we don't have your
income from this email but um it's not
it's not overspending but it was a
really dumb idea to open a business with
a loan it's why we tell people don't do
that um ouch I'm so sorry man it takes
your breath away when this happens
number one you got the failure of the
business hanging around your neck and
then you've got this reminder every
month that we failed when we may have to
make these huge payments so um couple of
things number one I would consider
rolling up your sleeves and uh working
six jobs and just paying it down like
anybody else with it great Gale
intensity that's going to be the best
way number two if you have enough equity
in your home to clear the loan you may
want to sell the house and be out of it
be done with it and go go rent and start
fresh from there um because you're going
to lose the house if you file a Chapter
7 bankruptcy and if you file a 13 you're
paying payments again it's of no benefit
you can pay payments pay
payments so oh man it's awful sorry
you're facing that yeah the success of
businesses largely relies on you know
this cash flow and when you have
$200,000 in debt to start and with the
high failure rate of some of these small
businesses it just makes the problem
worse yeah I'm we're huge proponents of
small business Entre leadership we work
with about 10,000 of them and I do the
entree leadership podcast once a week um
talking to small business people every
week and uh we love doing our ENT
leadership events uh and every single
time we tell you to stay away from loans
particularly it's it's an oxymoron that
you say these small business
administration screws more small
businesses than anybody else I mean
isn't that weird I mean it's just it's
just weird it sets you up for failure
number one cause a small business
failure cash flow problems what to cause
cash flow problems don't pay your taxes
on time and have a big SBA loan this
causes cash flow problems every time all
right Jared is with us in Jacksonville
Florida hi Jared how are you I'm doing
good how are y'all better than I deserve
what's
up um so I've been living paycheck to
paycheck lately and uh just want to know
if you guys have any advice for me I'm
I'm starting on baby step number one
right now and just trying to work my way
up to being debt free do we ever my
friend well one thing you can check out
it's totally free we just did a live
stream called Break the cycle where we
help people break that paycheck to
paycheck cycle at ramseys solutions.com
brethe cycle but the key here is to get
on a budget and start looking at what is
going on with my money because you make
money right how much do you make uh
right now I'm making 65,000 a year but
as of the 1 of February I'll be making
72 wonderful and how much debt do you
have uh around $80,000 in debt okay so
now this becomes a math problem we have
80,000 in debt we make 75 how do we pay
this off aggressively we recommend
budgeting plus the debt snowball and
that's going to help you aggressively
pay down this debt smallest to largest
balance and we start with a th000 bucks
in the bank do you have a th000 in the
bank I do not I'm working on getting
that right now but just with my bills
and rent and everything and I'm a very
list spender to be honest with you yes
yeah yeah that's what's so your first
step is to get organized and get on a
written budget a detailed plan pretend
like you were managing this money for
someone else you had 70 coming in and
you need to clean up an 80
mess right okay and if you if I hired
you to do that for someone else you
could do it but the problem is the
partying on the weekends the problem is
the impulse
spending uh the problem is you're just
you know you're out of control and
showing up in your money and you said
that I didn't right yes okay so we know
what the solution is it's the guy in
your mirror he's the solution to this
issue so uh jump online at uh and watch
that break the cycle get the every
dollar app and uh start using it it's
free to start and jump in there and
start using it and start to put together
your budget and make the money that you
have behaved instead of wondering where
it went this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
Personality YouTube host and uh author
of The brand new book Breaking Free from
broke is my co-host today open phones at
[Music]
88255 225 that's
225 a lot of you calling in the last
several days have been brand new to this
whole ramsy thing uh the stuff that we
teach and so it probably is a good idea
I just decided this um for for George
and I to spend a segment outlining some
of the basics number one uh when I was
28 years old I'm 63 now so when I was 28
years old I filed bankruptcy because I'd
gone into too much debt I lost
everything and I got the opportunity to
start over I went on a quest to learn
how money really works because at that
point I had a finance degree and several
other letters and licenses after my name
that said I was supposed to know
something about money but I was broke so
obviously what I learned was wrong and
and I discovered this thing from Rich
old people called common sense and it
also lined up with what the Bible says
about money get out of debt live on less
than you make have a written plan called
a budget invest and
save be
generous and we've capsulized that into
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else else
and then we started teaching people what
order to do these things in because all
these questions came up about insurance
and retirement and kids college and we
put together a process called the baby
steps and it became a 10 million copy
book called The Total Money Makeover
teaching people how to do the baby steps
also about 11 million people now have
been through Financial Peace University
the class that we teach all of these
things outline what we the Ramsey
personalities call the Ramsay way which
is now a proven plan to become wealthy
not only get out of debt but to become
wealthy it is the
fastest right way to build wealth so
George Let's unpack the baby steps
absolutely so it's seven steps in a very
particular order and they have to be
done in this order with intentionality
and intensity so baby step one is a
$1,000 starter emergency fund this is a
small buffer between you and life as you
begin to pay off debt which is baby step
two pay off all Consumer Debt debt
except the mortgage using the debt
snowball method that means smallest to
largest balance we're ignoring the
interest rate we are focused on
behavioral momentum and progress here
and you roll the payment into the next
one and into the next one as you knock
the small ones out and you're debt free
an average on 18 to 24 months people
following the plan once you have no debt
now we can get that starter emergency
fund beefed up to a fully uh funded
emergency fund of 3 to six months of
expenses not income and most people do
that in 6 to 12 months one we have no
debt and a pile of money to protect us
from life's emergencies a rainy day fund
Now we move on to investing what's
interesting is baby steps 4 56 are done
simultaneously but in order so you're
going to start by investing 15% of your
household income into retirement 401ks
IAS once you have that plate spinning
you got 15% start start funding the kids
college and that looks different for
everyone and once you have some money
going to the college fund now we can
start aggressively attacking that
Mortgage and pay them mortgage off uh
early and that takes you to step seven
which is build wealth and give and when
you don't have any payments in the world
it's amazing no house payment no car
payment no student loan that's been
around so long you think it's a pet
Master Card is no longer your master you
haven't discovered bondage or American
distress instead you're free and you now
have control of your most powerful
wealth building too which is your income
and um the steps one through three the
start emergency fund getting out of Deb
except the house and the and a fully
funded emergency fund are done with
great intensity if you're broke friends
aren't making fun of you you're not
doing it
right if broke people make fun of you if
fat people make fun of your diet you're
doing it right think about it you have
you know you're going to eat that you're
just going to yeah so there you go so
that that's the thing now now with great
intensity you're not going out to eat
you're you're eating at home it's
cheaper and it's better for you you're
not going on vacation you're broke broke
people don't need to go on vacation so
you're you're getting out of debt you
list your debts smallest to largest and
you attack them with a Vengeance we call
it gazelle intensity after the gazelle
running from the
cheetah he's running for his freaking
life so act like it otherwise you work
your whole life and you make more money
than 90% of the people on the planet
make and you retire broke and hope the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of you that's a stupid butt
plan you're going to count on social
insecurity no you're not don't do that
then when you get those three things out
of the way I mean think about it what if
you had no payments but a house payment
and $155,000 cash in the bank well you'd
be in the top four or 5% of Americans
for one thing you could breathe can you
breathe that in just just a little piece
right there Financial Peace two words
that don't go together like Airline
service right I mean come on list it out
there now then you start doing as George
said four five and six simultaneously
retirement kids college and paying off
the house with other money we can find
you're going to do that not with
intensity but with intentionality we're
going to get off the gazelle thing we
actually can go out to eat buy a couch
we can go on vacation again upgrade the
car in cash got to upgrade the car cuz
you're probably driving a hoopie at this
point cuz we got rid of this stupid
$85,000 car have you lost your
mind and wondering why you're broke see
this is what we do it's Grandma's common
sense if you can't pay for it you don't
buy it for the rest of your life because
you will destroy your most powerful
wealth building tool which is your
income shut up be a grownup no whining
allowed suck it up buttercup that's
Ramsey plan
that's it it's that simple and it's that
hard and people think Dave well this is
going to take me 30 years no people on
average baby steps 1 through three to
get out of debt and have the emergency
fund you're talking two and a half to
three years even paying off the house
the people following the baby steps they
pay off their house on average in seven
years exactly and the and typically they
are millionaires easily within the first
decade from the time they start this
stuff so how old are you I'm 34 now and
a you're a millionaire Dead free house
and everything and I started this plan
when $40,000 in Consumer Debt and you
were how old 23 years old okay so 11
years from then to today yeah and by the
by actually at about 10 years you were
there and yes you were working here but
no he didn't make that much I don't pay
that well I'm kidding I'm a dou2
employee I didn't I'm not some
entrepreneur side Hustler guy everyone
thinks you have to have some kind of
weird hustle to make you cannot out earn
your stupidity you got I tried it I went
broke trying that I'm good at making
money I've always been good at making
money what I wasn't good at is taking
care of it once I made it and that's how
I went broke at 28 years old and then
from then on I've been telling everybody
else not to do this Dave Ramsey just
doesn't understand Dave Ramsey's done it
shut
up I am the story shut up no excuses
wuss go do it this is the ramsy
shop
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window cover rings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any mislead quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
save up to 35% off everything sitewide
that's blinds.com to learn
[Music]
more
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America George is the author of the
brand new book Breaking Free from
broke we'd love to have you pick it up
ramsy Solutions or anywhere great books
are sold ramsy solutions.com to be
precise thanks for hanging out with us
the phone number here is
5225 want to say thank you to all of you
we've been asking you to subscribe click
the Subscribe button click the follow
button uh and you have been we
appreciate it uh and you've been leaving
some really nice five-star reviews on
the show thank you for that you're very
helpful we appreciate you and of course
you can uh help the big thing is share
the show if the
platform that you're on has a share
capability just click share and send it
to somebody or cut the you know cut the
link out or if you're listening on talk
radio just tell people where you're
listening just share tell people what
you're doing and um you know uh we
appreciate it because we know it's
happening because we just hit number one
on all Apple podcasts the other day
number one of all of them that's kind of
mindblowing and we've had our billionth
download one billion downloads and
that's because of you guys thank you so
much for that all right up next is going
to be Jim in Raleigh North Carolina hi
Jim how are you I'm well hi Dave um so
my question today Dave is so me and my
family were on baby step four and we are
we want to buy a house and we we've
we've saved up you know about 25 $30,000
to buy a house but good for you you know
my my profession is very volle you know
I'm a college football coach um so like
we could we could be somewhere a year we
could be somewhere 10 years we could be
moving across the country country and
and we're just trying to figure out when
is the best time to buy a house you
we've got we' got a young family and
we're we're kind of sick of running we
kind we want our own spot and we're just
kind of trying to figure out when is the
best time for us to do it do you have a
winning
season this last year we did not okay so
when you
moving right now we're kind of looking
right now we're looking
so we're I'm a young coach and you we're
looking and we're just trying to figure
out okay this next job is are we going
to
buy it kind of depends on you know where
we end up but um just trying to figure
out should we even be considering like I
said yes you should buy you should buy
you should buy because we don't know now
here's what you want to look for Nick uh
in your situ or I'm sorry Jim in your
situation um typically you need to own a
house in most markets a couple of years
otherwise you're going to lose money on
it okay but in most cases you're going
to be there two
years yep okay and the way to be careful
about that is if you are going into some
uh job where it's a super small town and
there's not much of a market you need to
be careful but if it's a metro area
where there's a good market and you can
turn the property over then you're
probably going to make money after 2
years most cases just historically now
if you want to be real nerdy about it
here's how you can do it when you are
looking at a neighborhood in the next
town that you're going to move into ask
the real estate agent and get one of the
good Ramsey trusted real estate brokers
that we endorse ask the agent to pull
some MLS multiple listing service
statistics for you here are the two
stats you want okay number one just say
within a f mile radius of this house
we're looking at just like a drop a dot
in the middle of it five mile radius you
following me yep what is the average
annual growth rate in prices for the
last 10
years got it yep now keep in mind you
have 20 in there and 20 is screwed up
statistics because after the fouchy
pandemic people came out of their houses
like a Baptist looking for a casserole
and ran the real estate market up right
yep okay so that you got an anomaly in
the stats there but other than that
look for it hard and you're looking for
average annual rate of return a
correlating number is the second one and
that's average days on the market
Doom how long does it take the house to
sell on average in a f mile radius of
this house so let me give you a couple
of different number ways you look at
that number okay if it comes back the
average annual rate of return on the
house is 2% and the days on the market
are
270 9 months you're going to to lose
your butt don't
buy yep cuz it's going to take nine
months to sell it you're going to make
4% in two years and it's going to cost
you 12% to get out of the house you're
going to lose money and you're going to
have trouble selling it right the other
end of the spectrum would that'd be a
slow draggy Market the other end of the
spectrum would be average days on the
market seven
days and the appreciation rate is 10% a
year you're going to make 20% in two
years and you can dump the thing in a
heartbeat yeah you buy
there you see how I'm doing these stats
so and and you'll find them running
together okay you don't have long days
on the market and high appreciation
rates it's very
unusual they go together it's usually
usually an active market and you've got
good appreciation rates so but if you're
moving you know we talked to the
military guys about this too if you're
in the military don't buy a house
because they move your butt every two
years unless you move into a metro area
but if you move in one of these Podunk
military towns where the whole economy
is the military all you've got is a
bunch of houses on the market all the
time from the last goobers that moved in
there and bought a house okay so you
can't that they don't appreciate and you
can't get rid of them but if you're
moving if you're in the Navy and you're
moving into San Diego which is fairly
typical by the way uh or you're moving
into Virginia Beach or something like
that you got a very active market and
you're going to be able to get out of it
and make some money so two years is you
need to know you're going to be there
two years and look at those numbers
nerdy and yes you should buy cuz you
might have a 17-year run Sabin
did you never know dream big and the
last thing Dave that you've talked about
before is not over buying in the
neighborhood yeah don't don't don't buy
the top of the market buy middle to
bottom of the market in that
neighborhood so if the houses on that
street are most of them are
$350,000 don't buy the $450,000 one buy
the 350 or300 one because people don't
drive down that street looking for that
price range they drive down the street
looking for 350
so don't buy 450 on that that top of the
market on that street that's a good
point George so and you know use other
Common Sense things like is the house
ugly when you stand in front of it you
can't get over ugly ugly is to the Bone
man so you can't get over if it's just
your standard has no curb appeal and
you're getting a deal when you sell it
you're going to give it a deal cuz it's
got no curb appeal it's
ugly there are houses out there that are
trust me are ugly and uh so but I have
overlooked them in the name of price
sometimes and it's bit me in the butt so
I don't do it anymore I buy stuff that's
pretty or can be pretty when I dress it
up a little bit well sometimes it's you
know we can swap the carpet in the paint
that's an easy fix but if you put
lipstick on a pig it's still a pig yeah
yeah so there you go good good question
I like your question and yeah I think
you're you know you're you're going to
you're going to buy and you're going to
be fine and you're going to end up you
know you are going to move it's the
nature of your business I got football
coaches in our family and you know you
are going to move it's part of it uh but
hopefully you got runs that are longer
than two years and you're in good solid
markets where you can make some money
maybe if he buys he'll be more
incentivized to be a better Coach and
more wins is that how that works no I
think I think he's going to be a good
coach he's a great coach he's call he's
listening to the Ramy show that tells me
he's a he's a wise man there you go
there you go he's a great coach what do
you mean yeah I mean you know you don't
you don't become a better Coach because
you buy a house that just makes you more
stuck you know that's true you know and
and the other thing come somebody may
come along want to pay you double and
you want to leave oh but you got you're
tied this asset it's not e easy to just
up and leave yeah you got to buy my
house and buy out my contract in order
to get me you know then you got you got
two problems right so uh I don't think I
can coach little league at this point
Dave have you ever done some coaching uh
not at not not been paid no I just just
avoided the just Ministry time yeah
Daniel when Daniel was playing ice
hockey he's a little bitty guy we
coached from four years old till 13 at
13 the mouth kicked in and I quit o so I
can't do mouth and I would get put in
jail these days so um I think this could
be like a Netflix series it's a hockey
coach I mean you got a stick in my hand
you're not going to do this so it's like
no America needs to see Dave Rams in
coaching Little League no it's not a
good idea it's I was a good I was sweet
to the kids I just don't I the
helicopter parents are morons you're
yelling at the parents not the kids at
that point sit down with them at the
first of every year listen I'm doing
this for free so I can hang out with my
son if you want to take over at any time
you can and if about it you're
going to be taken over so there you go
Dave Ramsey's rules of League this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why ref
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lumpsum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Seth
and Sierra yes Sierra are with us I want
to make sure I pronounce your name right
welcome you guys good to have you where
do you live Clarksville Clarksville
Tennessee well welcome just up the road
you had to slip and slide a little to
get down here yes sir we did all right
how much debt have you guys paid off
$110,000 all right how long did that
take 36 months good for you and your
range of income during that time started
at 38 ended at 120 good Lord okay what
do youall do for a living I'm a police
officer and I'm in accounting all right
so how did you jump your income from 38
to 120 somebody got a job you I got a
job I lost my job because of Co and then
I became a leasing agent at our
apartment complex I did that for 2 years
and then I got an accounting job um and
then that was the last hole for our debt
free so I've been in that job for almost
well two years January so between the
two of us we had five jobs okay I got
two other jobs and she got two jobs wow
getting it what kind of debt was the
110,000 oh we had 10,000 on a credit
card 13,000 on a car and $87,000 in stud
loans wow okay so criminal justice
degree or what yes sir criminal justice
degree okay all right I was guessing
Okay good very good so uh what happened
36 months ago you said three years ago
this has got to change yes sir um coming
out the backside of the pandemic right
in short that's what happened the
pandemic hit and uh we were doing a lot
better off than a lot of other people I
mean we had money in the savings account
but we just a whole lot of normal she
lost her job you know she called me when
I was at work one day and said hey
they're they're they're telling us not
to come back into work so uh things got
really tight there for a minute and and
we were kind of still making it but kind
of too much month left at the end of the
money so I remember I was just laying in
bed and and she was laying there and she
was just really stressing about the
money and I I didn't like that so I was
like I I can't control a pandemic I
can't control anything else but I can
control how we spend our money and how
we move forward so uh I looked you up
well I looked up just how to manage
money better and your plan came across
and I was like this guy's plan works you
know so I just did it never heard of us
before that never never heard of you
before that um wow I just looked up like
how to how to manage money better and I
watched just about every YouTube video
it was funny she went to bed and then I
stayed up watching just about every
YouTube video of you I could watch and I
was like you know I'm not the smartest
you know guy but dang I can work dang it
I can work so I know how to work I know
how money I know how to work but that's
most of the battle when it comes to
getting out of debt is being willing to
do it and sacrifice and guys did it
working five jobs to get out of this
mess yep so the wakeup call is the
stress point then you're flipping
through these videos what were you
seeing there that made you say I can do
this what was it that gave you hope you
know every other every other plan that I
saw there was some kind of gimmick that
went with it you know zero interest
credit card or do this I'm like well
that just that just moves the problem
that doesn't fix the problem and I watch
Dave Ramsey does the baby steps live in
Dallas and you're screaming at us
telling us how St stupid we are and I'm
like you know what this guy that's one
of my favorite videos I think was that
from like the '90s or early 2000s you
did a thing I think on Fox I have no
idea I was I was watching I'm like this
guy's screaming about gazel and telling
me to go to work and call telling me
yeah this this guy yeah we don't sell
microwaves we sell crockpots I'm like
that's that's the plan I need right
there so okay I would like to add that I
wasn't on board at first because I was
like terrified because I just lost my
job I was on unemployment and he was
like we're getting out of debt and I was
like I don't have a job
like how can we do this like and he made
me watch your yeah so at first I called
you a fun terrorist Dave yeah got I am I
am a fun terrorist that's good I got on
board yeah looking back I feel violent
terrorist but fun looking back I feel
really bad cuz she went to sleep with
with her husband and she woke up with
some new person that just went to get
out of go we'll blame YouTube for that
you go down the rabbit hole of Ramy
videos you walk out a different man oh
that's one that is great thank you
YouTube wow that's very cool so you guys
that within a few days of that rolled up
your sleeves got on a budget and started
I guess yes sir absolutely okay so way
to go what was what was the most
lucrative side Hustle the one that
surprised you're like oh my gosh this is
pretty incredible well actually um I was
like you did electric work I did
electric work and I think the the most
lucrative for me was working security at
the
churchend they decided we were really
blessed I mean God really came through
in a lot of ways for us in this and the
church was like hey we need somebody to
do security can you do it sure I'm here
anyway so they uh paid me like 40 bucks
an hour just yeah it was pretty good so
that that came through really and then
you got some on the job experience there
now as a police officer absolutely
that's really cool are you are you a
police officer in Clarksville yes if I
ever get pulled over there I'll be like
hey I know Seth does that do anything
for you probably not but you know I'll
try I say and I got commissions with
leasing Apartments so that was also
she's really good yeah yeah very good
good good job you guys well done what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of dead is now that you've done
it communication sticking it out
together and also trusting the Lord we
had never tithed before Oh so we started
doing that and that's when everything
changed yeah yeah it really did it
really did and we started handling money
God's way it really what church are you
in there uh First Baptist in Clarksville
yeah okay excellent that's where we go
uh but yeah perseverance um you know we
had a lot of things happen we had to pay
a lot of stuff out of pocket you know we
had a move in there we had some medical
bills in there we had to pay but just
get right back on that horse and keep
going and and lean on each other you
know I there'll be times I'm working 90
hours hard 36 months very hard very hard
very hard the end now that you're 100%
free it's amazing was it worth it yes
sir absolutely I don't want to go back
in it no no never I don't want to ever
have to live like that again it's live
like that so never never live like that
right yes sir it's funny we kind of
switched roles Seth was wanting to save
the money save the money when we were
going through the debt journey and I was
wanting to spend it and then uh once we
got Deb free I was like I'm a hoarder
now like want to save all the money and
that's like I want to buy something now
we're finally out she's calling me about
a $10 expense at Walmart and I'm like
just buy it we have the money you got to
rewire your brain to go oh we're free
now we're free we can enjoy life
absolutely way to go guys
congratulations proud of y'all thank you
sir well done very well done this is uh
it's honoring to us to hear that the the
YouTube uh videos in the middle of the
night gave you some hope when everything
was closing in on you absolutely you
know and that's that's a cool thing
that's very neat um and you know
obviously you got access to that all
free that's that's perfect that's the
way it should be I Love It the YouTube
team and the SEO team working on hey he
searches for how to manage money we want
to show up we want to give people hope
instead of some Shortcut scheme that's
out there yeah that wasn't an accident
yeah very good congratulations you guys
hey we've got the uh live and give box
for you for you to be able to enjoy some
of these things and give some away the
baby steps millionaires book uh because
that's your next step you will be one
you are on track to do that for sure The
Total Money Makeover book and uh of
course the Financial Peace University
membership uh we want you to enjoy all
of those things or give them depending
on how you want to do it it's the live
and give box uh congratulations again
way to go very cool did you have people
uh telling you you shouldn't be doing
this that you were crazy people thought
we were nuts yeah we had people that
just kind of didn't understand the
urgency not that they didn't support it
it's just they didn't understand like
the urgency of getting out of debt cuz
we're so we're still young so I had so
many people telling me don't pay off
your student loans they're going to
forgive it they're going to forgive it
I'm like I've never trusted the
government for anything so I'm like no
and these are people that would never
say that about anything else but they
say it about that that's what strange
right yeah well how do you like me now
huh there we go to be Keith right
exactly way to go you guys excellent
stuff all right Seth and Sierra
Clarksville Tennessee
$110,000 paid off in 36 long months
making 38 to 120 they're free count it
down let's hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1
we're Deb free
[Applause]
yeah that's how it's done
[Music]
I know how to work that was his for the
day it's a mic drop right there if
you're not scared of work I'm pretty
sure you're like Invincible in this
economy yeah like you know having you
know having common sense is like having
a superpower it's pretty crazy this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
George camel Ramsey personality author
of the brand new book Breaking Free from
broke is my co-host today thanks for
hanging out with us America it's book
launch week for George we're all really
excited about this book it is selling
like crazy you guys it's going to be a
great help to you we're we're just
pumped for you Jacob is with us in mon
Georgia hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave how you doing better than
I deserve what's
up well I went a little bit crazy last
year um me and my wife jumped on a
journey to pay down as much debt as
possible we paid off $240 000 last year
way to go but um I also spent everything
I had in my savings everything that we
had made together I mean I I unloaded
just about everything into it we still
got uh
$14,000 you know between savings and
checkings I got $5,000 in cash um but I
need a tractor to be able to take care
of my
property and I know that you are 100%
against you know any kind of financing
but a new track these days between know
50 and 60,000 be able to have the right
size of do you know my
property um so I don't know you know is
financing okay especially at 0% for 60
60 months
or yeah I'm show you went crazy getting
out of
debt and you know that we tell people
not to borrow money and you called Here
Wanting to financial
tractor I I just don't know like I said
I think I kind of put myself into a boat
know my property is going up taking
over what do you make a
year uh last year we made
210,000 um I am laid off my
job um and so I'm you know going off my
wife's uh income at the moment and she's
a women's health nurse practitioner so
she what does she make
120 okay and so when are you going back
to
work um we're not sure yet
um no I mean you're not looking for
another job you're waiting on
them um uh we kind of are making a
decision at the moment as to whether I'm
going to be a stay-at-home dad to homes
School our two girls because we're not
exactly too fond of the um school
systems um so we're kind of in in
between at this point she's we're both
talking about um you know getting some
cattle and you know just making some
money off of the farm since we've
already got the property how much of
acreage do you have 42 and a half
acres
okay does not take a $62,000 tractor to
take care of 42 Acres
dude
seriously it's not that big a spread
okay you know
that and you can't afford it you don't
have the money so um and you're not
making a living on the 42 Acres you may
have a few cattle but you don't even
need a tractor for cattle have somebody
run a bush hog over there ever so often
or something maybe but um especially if
you're going to decide to stay at
home uh and cut your income almost in
half
right why don't you go back to your to
to your old career even if it's not with
the company that led you
off um kind of the uh as much as I'd
like to we're looking at the well-being
of taking care of our children what were
they doing while you were
working well me and my wife are four
states away from each other and uh
you're four states away from each other
well that's an interesting piece of
information halfway through the
conversation we uh we did something
crazy we went all out to pay off as much
debt as humanly possible to where Ian we
paid Down The House halfway and uh all
other debt is gone so you're there where
is
she uh she's in Georgia we're both in
Georgia now she's back to
mon yes that that's where she's been I
went to Ohio to work construction oh I
see and that's what you got laid off
from yes sir
I see okay so not only do you not want
to be
uh not only worried about the kids in
school but you're also worried about
being away from your family all the time
that's fair that's a lot that's a lot
better plan okay uh I mean you could but
but you might not make as much as you
used to make if you work construction in
your area right yes sir uh it'd be cut
down to uh between 50 to 60,000 so what
do you owe on your what do you how the
only debt you have left is your property
yes sir uh we owe uh
260,000
wow so you paid off other stuff then not
that uh she uh the house was uh almost
half a million dollars and then I paid
off her car also and then my other house
in Kentucky is paid off what's the house
in
Kentucky uh it's one I bought while I
was going to school um was something I
bought online what's it worth I did 200
to 220 sell it and pay off your house
and buy a
tractor why do you have a house in
Kentucky you didn't set out to do that
you ended up with it from back in the
day if you didn't own it right now you
wouldn't write a check for $200,000 to
buy a house in Kentucky Tennessee or
Arkansas right it's very random in your
life now I understand how you got there
but I would sell it and pay off your
mortgage and use your fabulous fact that
you have no payments in the world to
save up and pay cash for a used tractor
not 60 maybe 30 but pay for
it okay oh the house why do you want to
hang on to this house you're not GNA do
that are
you uh no I got some attachment uh we've
talked about for the last year sell it
I've got um I've got $130 to $150,000
equity in it who cares sell it do you
care more about your kids or this Random
House why what are you attached to a
house in Kentucky
for I had it for going the Bible College
who cares Jesus didn't live there take a
picture and put it on the
wall right yeah I mean it's it's it's
not an heirloom it's a
house it's not your great grandfather's
Bible it's a
house I mean dude really okay I I don't
think I can help you man but that's what
I would do if I woke up in your shoes I
would sell the house in Kentucky and I
would solve a lot of my problems by
doing that and get the house that you're
living in paid off I think I heard you
could pay it off I thought it was paid
for and then I thought he said he owed
130 so now I'm confused I kept learning
new facts along this whole thing
unfolded but you kept saying we keep do
we did this crazy thing we did this
crazy thing was accordion but um I think
the craziest thing is to keep this house
when you have this dream to run this
property and homeschool the kids and yet
you're hanging on to this property lot
you got you got too many conflicting
priorities and so we need to decide what
it is we really want in this life and
give up a bunch of the other stuff to
get what you really want and if you
really want to be home with the kids
great if that's really what's driving
this I think you really want to be off
the road and I think you won't play
gentleman farmer that's what I think and
I think you're blaming your kids so I'm
going to be real hard on you now but um
um that's okay and by the way 42 acres
is a gentleman farmer that's not a
that's not somebody making a living so
um uh anyway yeah you do what you want
to do but uh if I were in your shoes I
would get a job in construction and I
would sell the house in Kentucky and I
would buy a used tractor for cash and I
would pay off my house that's what I
would do but you're going to do what
you're going to do but thanks for
calling appreciate you interesting story
at the very least lot going on there
yeah yeah moral the story too is if you
move four states away temporarily and
take a high-end you know high paying
construction job if you're willing to
sacrifice being away from your family
which he did for a short period of time
there you can make a ton of money and
that's what he did and I don't recommend
that for a way of life but I do
appreciate Jacob's work ethic oh yeah
being willing to go do that for a short
period of time to accomplish some of the
goals he just got stuff out of line in
the in in the process and um then when
he suddenly got sent home I I think it
threw him into a tizzy yeah this might
be kind of a midlife crisis situation
trying to figure out what's next but
hope he figures it out soon absolutely
gave him the plan thank you Jacob that
puts us hour the ramsy show in the
[Music]
books
[Applause]
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality author of the brand new book
Breaking Free from broke is my co-host
today this hour is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour you don't know
what that is several years ago we
started taking calls from people who are
actual millionaires or
greater and asking them things about
their life so that you could actually
parallel them and be one of them and put
aside all the mythology that is out
there about wealth in America
today number one myth that's out there
that the Hope Steelers out there the oh
the characters the Lefty crazy
Communists say is you can't become
wealthy in America today because all
wealth is
inherited lie number one lie number two
all wealthy people are Crooks that's how
they got their money lie number three
all wealthy people are famous
entertainers sports
figures rock stars Etc line number three
line number four they are
brilliant all millionaires have 4.2 GPA
they're all rocket
scientists nope we will prove that to
you today by talking to real
Millionaires and have done that for many
many years now that led us into doing
what became the uh largest study of
millionaires ever done in North America
we did it at Ramsey research with
outside research firms looking over our
shoulder to make sure there was no
confirmation bias make sure that our
research methodology was accurate and
perfect because we knew you lefties out
there wouldn't go along with it and
because you want to to say that America
is uh the dream is dead and that you
can't win the little men can't get ahead
there's systemic problems with the
economy and all that bull crap that some
of you pedal out there and so we knew
that that would come up and that you
would accuse our research of being
inaccurate and so the the research
methodologies airtight and double
checked double checked that's good
double checked and um so if you don't
agree with the actual conclusions of
studying
10,167 millionaires you're what's known
as
wrong and we're going to unpack some of
that for you and talk to real
millionaires today we have to start with
a basic definition because I heard a
United States congresswoman the other
day God people are dumb how do you even
elect these people
she says he's not a millionaire he
doesn't make a million dollars a
year oh God yikes this is a congressman
unbelievable how in the world did you
get out of the sixth grade who voted for
these people people that didn't get out
of the sixth grade oh my gosh so let me
the definition of a millionaire is not a
feeling it's not a moral construct it's
a math thing and it has nothing to do
with your income
a millionaire is someone who has a net
worth of a millionaire of a million
dollars a net worth is assets minus
liabilities equals your net worth some
of you have a negative net worth because
you owe more than you
own but a millionaire has at least $1
million in the bottom right hand corner
of the spreadsheet when you take what
you own minus what you owe regardless of
your
income you can make a million a year and
not be a millionaire cuz you spend $2
million a year like you're in Congress
there you go so that that that's the
whole thing so we've got to you know
that's what a millionaire is if you are
an actual millionaire we don't care how
you got your money whether you inherited
it maybe you were a crook maybe you're a
famous person um maybe you have a 4.2
GPA I don't care if you got if you want
it in the lottery if you're a
millionaire and your net worth what you
own minus what you owe is greater than a
million dollars we want to talk to you
this hour the phone number is
88255 225 our first millionaire is Erica
in Austin Texas Erica what is your net
worth hi Dave my net worth is just North
of a million dollars right at a million
perfect give me a little breakdown in
that how does that break out by
category so I would say 80% of that is
in um real estate we have two rental
properties and about 20% of that would
be in cash Investments 401K Ross that
kind of stuff okay cool how old are you
I'm 36 and my husband is 38 oh did this
young how much of this $1 million did
you
inherit zero zero okay and what has been
the range of your working income you
started working in your early 20s what's
the worst year and the best year of your
income oh I mean if we're going all the
way back probably 65 early in my 20s and
um The Last Five Years our average
together has been anywhere from 280 to
340 okay perfect all right and uh what's
your career what do you
do uh we are both Technical Recruiters
ah very good very good great career feel
right now what you degrees you got foure
degrees um so I have a bachelor's and a
master's in HR and my husband has no
degrees okay what was your
GPA I want to say I don't remember
exactly but it was probably around 3.5
perfect okay good all right
um well you did this
quick I mean what do you attribute this
to how do you how do you become a
millionaire by the time you're 36 what
do you what do you blame it
on um a little bit of luck in the real
estate market and just kind of buying
young and and buying modest um and then
those real estate properties growing
over time and then every time we um
moved out we just rented the house and
and we had the equity from rsus from uh
Facebook and from other tech companies
to kind of invest in new properties but
we've always lived you know very
modestly in terms of our mortgages that
we were um taking out so and your
overall lifestyle too yeah yeah yeah you
piled up some good cash here this is
good because you've not been making 240
for that long no yeah yeah I would say
in the last like five or so years we've
we've definitely stepped up our income
and we also work part-time jobs in the
evening to to supplement some some
things and I wish I would have known
about the baby steps a little bit
earlier in my 20s and we're kind of
going back and working the steps as we
go we paid off the truck last year we're
going to pay off my car this year in a
few months and then really hit the
investment piece hard and and start um
uh you know working the full steps I
would say way to go well what would you
tell you know that person who's in their
late 20s early 30s who's like how do I
actually become a millionaire and not
wait till I'm 60 cuz you guys did it
yeah I would say max out that Roth and
401K from the minute you entered the
workforce um invest as much as you
possibly can and live modestly live on
lesson you make invest in retirement
accounts way to go yeah four times I
heard her say live
modestly she said that a lot you said
that a lot Erica I'm proud of you way to
go hero very well done millionaire at
36 first case in point how much did they
inherit Z zero how much of did they
steal from other people none did they
have a
4.2 no not doctors not lawyers not
athletes do they play in the NFL no do
they play in a rock band no maybe on the
weekends there you go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
we're taking calls from real
millionaires people who did it not your
broke brother-in-law who votes wrong
this is the phone number
5225 we want to learn from you how it is
really done if you're a real millionaire
or greater a millionaire again George
George was saying at the break that
people were saying you're not a
millionaire because you count your
house on on YouTube comments which is
proof that people's parents are cousins
that are in the YouTube comments well
they like to form their own definition
Dave that's all it is they're redefining
millionaire yeah like people redefine
recession if they don't want there to be
one yeah so that's one way to do it let
me help you with it this house is an
asset it accounts in the formula this is
a an
accounting definition if you take an
accounting class and you learn about
balance sheets and net worth this is not
something you get to make up based on
your little hurt butt
feelings it's not a moral
construct if you have antique
cars that are assets that are worth for
$100,000 that counts towards your net
worth I don't care if you like antique
cars I don't care if you think they
don't run well none of this comes up in
the discussion the actual thing is
a definition God that's aggravating
George oh trust me I know Dave and they
say well he'd have to he'd have to sell
the house and it's all IL liquid assets
so it doesn't count I'm like do you not
know the definition of an asset wow
here's the other one Dave I get on the
YouTube comments well he's not a
millionaire because it's him and his
wife and so if they divorce and he would
get he would be half a millionaire and
I'm like I don't know how to you people
you really don't want to win you want to
just figure out a way to lose and C so
everybody you have to you you know let's
figure out how we can be a loser I want
to I want to I'm going to figure out a
definition where I get to be a loser and
it's okay and the faceless YouTube
commenter with no profile picture with
username 14587 you know that's what
keeps me up night Dave is that is that
troll behind the comment going how do I
just get through to this idiot I don't
think there's a way yeah I I see the
difference is you actually read those
okay God help you George why do you do
that it gives me fuel Dave it doesn't
give me fuel it gives me indigestion
Dave is in Indianapolis Dave what is
your net
worth hey Dave uh my wife and I have
accumulated 3.2 million all right so 1.6
for you I'm kidding
okay all right and give me a little
breakdown in that
3.2 sure so in Ira's traditional nth uh
that is at 2.4 million wow uh most of
that has come from uh 401K rollovers
from previous
jobs uh got some in brokerage account
about
192 uh 210 in cash and our house is
worth 345 and then we got uh 53,000 and
a 529 fund
way to go how old are you I'm 60 good
how much of this did you
inherit uh well actually two years ago I
got
$200,000 okay were you already a
millionaire then oh yeah okay so you did
not become a millionaire because of an
inheritance just to be clear that is
clear okay all right I'm just asking I'm
going to make sure okay now so the
income range your best year working
income and your worst
year uh for our household it would have
been 70 for worst and about 180 for the
best cool all right what do you'all do
for a living what was your career or is
your career I was in uh healthc care
both of us are I was a uh radiation
therapist and she is in healthc care
administration okay four-year
degree uh mine's a four-year degree and
hers is uh Masters okay all right and
what was your
GPA I was a three-o eight and she had a
3.5 awesome very cool all right so if
you're talking to somebody and you are
that is 30 half your age can they still
become 3 point have a net worth of 3.2
million at age 60 and if they can what
would you tell them to do oh my gosh
yeah they can first of all uh you got to
live way below your
means the second thing is stay the heck
out of debt you got to stay out of debt
and kind of distinguish between your
wants and your
needs and uh the third thing I would say
is you start taking advantage of your
work for a 1K started doing that as
early as possible and uh the other thing
I did was once I hit 50 I took you know
that extra you could put in as the
catchup and uh I just put as much into
401ks as I possibly could way to go
excellent excellent good work
so are you guys TV people or book people
you watch TV at night or read
books well my wife is a book person I
I'm neither one I hate to say that's
okay that's all right that's all right
good good stuff all right what kind of
car do you drive me I got a 2012 Honda
Civic wow what she drive and my wife has
2012 uh Kia Soul okay and you're net
worth 3.2 million just to remind the
listeners out there what you said
earlier okay driving 12-year-old very
reasonable used cars absolutely amazing
way to go hero proud of you man thanks
for calling in I love it LC is in
Seattle Luke what's your net worth hi
Dave our net worth is 1.1 million very
cool all right give me a little
breakdown on that by
category uh most of it's in retirement
so 401K two Roth IRAs in mutual funds
that's about 4
73,000 um next is home equity we've got
about
309,000 in the house and uh shortterm
taxable savings kind of for goals here
coming up in the future it's mostly just
cash or cash equivalence like treasury
bills ibonds um it's about
170,000 uh we've got an HSA in mutual
funds about
51,000 and two paid for vehicles at a
little less than
46,000 then a little bit of cash and
check in emergency fund how old are you
uh I'm 34 and my wife is 31 oh getting
young millionaires today so how much of
this 1.1 net worth did you
inherit uh zero zero okay what was your
best working Year back in your 20s and
or lately and your worst working year
income wasse since you started
working uh almost 12 years ago right out
of college uh my worst working year I
was taken home about $1,200 to $1,500 a
month and um all the way up to about
400,000 now whoa okay what do you do for
a living I'm a captain for a major US
Airline okay so you fly Jets okay cool
and what about your
wife uh she's uh she volunteers here at
home in our community mainly through our
church okay cool you and you said you've
got a four-year degree in avionics or
what uh in in Flight technology yes a
fouryear bachelor degree and what was
your uh
GPA about 3.6 six all right very cool
all right so how long you've been making
serious Bank like
this uh mainly the later 20s later 20s
early 30s uh the first few years were
were really lean but most of yours is
sitting in retirement and into a home so
you started that early didn't you
correct yes in the early 20s yeah when
you weren't making any money and then
and then you go from there okay cuz I
guess what I'm trying to figure I'm
looking at the math I'm thinking through
the curve here on it it it you're not a
millionaire because you make 400 because
that's not happened long enough to cause
this to be here is am I right that's
correct it is all due to compound
interest and starting early yeah okay
all right so if
um wow okay all right cool do you know
hey let me ask you this side plan has
nothing to do with anything a a starting
pilot straight out of college right now
or straight out of flight school um like
they're flying regionals right yes what
are they making these
days uh quite a bit more than they were
making five or 10 years ago I would say
maybe somewhere in the vicinity of 60 to
100,000 okay I told a kid 60 the other
day so I wasn't too far off that's why
just checking myself all right good job
man way to go young millionaire I like
34 years old we're seeing a theme Here
Dave hey I got two in a row or two two
two of them that are young
I like it giving everybody hope that's
what this is It's facts you know facts
have a way of cutting through all the
garbage out there this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality author
of the brand new book Breaking Free from
broke is my co-host this is a baby steps
Mill millionaires theme hour where we
talk to real Millionaires and ask them
about their lives so that you can
compare and say gosh I could do that and
give you hope because you can do that
the four biggest lies told about
millionaires is they inherited their
money they are
Crooks they are famous entertainers rock
stars or sports
figures they have unusually high
intellect like a 4.2 GPA so let's deal
with the last three uh high GPA not true
the data tells us the average
millionaire has a
3.0 um the real estate that I'm sitting
in is worth somewhere around $600
million this one campus it's paid for
with a zero debt so that would be part
of my personal net worth my personal GPA
is a
2.97 um 3100s short of a 3.0 which still
pisses me off 40 years later can we redo
this there might have been beer involved
but yeah I think it's increased since
then yeah so anyway like IQ does it go
up over time no you can't you can't fix
it it's just it's like a it's like a bad
tattoo you're stuck with it so um yeah
so 3.0 is the average millionaire n or
GPA we don't find many that get a 1.2 I
mean you can't really be stupid or dumb
and do this I mean you you know they do
have good intellect and generally work
hard enough to get a grade right but
they're not prodigies and Geniuses no 1%
1% of the 16 million millionaires in
America are uh public figures that you
would know their name one out of a 100
one out of a 100 they are sports figures
rock stars country music stars whatever
you know uh actors out of Los Angeles or
whatever um but honestly people in the
Limelight are uh notorious for being we
work with them for being on one end of
the spectrum or the other they're either
Common Sense very careful got a good
business mind or they're dumber than a
rock when it comes to their finances and
you've heard all the stories of the
dumber than a rocks they they may they
make TV shows out of them and um they've
been on Sports 30 for 30 and all that
kind of stuff it's in terms of their
finances I don't mean they're personally
stupid they might be but um you know
they're really good at picking a guitar
and it ends there you know I mean that's
that's um that's what we run into in
Nashville I mean I've got a bunch of
friends country music people that you
guys know out there and uh some of them
are really good business minds and some
of
them just good musicians some of them
their wife can manage the checkbook I
mean that's it her husband you know it's
yeah so uh yeah bad news so the last one
uh not the last one last one we're going
to talk about in this segment is their
Crooks see that's the dumbest one to me
I can understand how you'd think it
takes a lot of intellect or the famous
people are millionaires that makes sense
but Crooks doesn't even make sense cuz
here's the way it works okay if you own
a business and you screw
people you mess them over because you're
a
crook do you do do your customers then
tell everybody to come do business with
you no they tell everybody to avoid that
person they're a crook
so Crooks in a capitalistic Society
especially where social media is there
and you can jump on Instagram and say
such and such a place ripped me off
Crooks have a tendency to not
Prosper versus Prosper you can't find
enough new people to steal from that
know don't know any of the other people
you stole from to run a business based
on crooking people it doesn't work so
that's just absolutely asinine I mean
Midol and Ponzi go to jail do not pass
go they go to jail now they pull it off
for a little while but it's not
sustainable wealth building so this idea
that you know all the people that ever
have any money or Crooks that's just
your redneck Backwoods idiot friend
who's jealous who can't find his butt
with both hands and the only way they
can describe it is oh they just they rip
everybody off that's how they got their
money now you're just dumb okay it
doesn't work in a capitalistic society
that doesn't work it's just easier to be
jealous Dave jealousy jealousy is I want
what you have Envy is worse than
jealousy Catholic Catholics call that
one of the seven deadly sins because
Envy is I don't not I not only want what
you have but I don't think I can get it
so I don't want you to have it so have
to tear down everything and tear you up
and get tall poppy syndrome the
Australians call it and cut down anybody
who sticks their head up and that's just
that's
just ridiculous so it doesn't work
doesn't work Katie Katie is in Detroit
Katie what's your net
worth hi Dave um our net worth is 1.2
million awesome give me a little break
down by
category so uh the bulk of that is in
retirement accounts about 600,000 good
um our home is paid off and worth about
350,000 okay and then the remainder is
in non-retirement mutual funds um our
kids college savings and cash good very
good how old are
you I am
30 my husband is 38 Wow way to go how
much of this 1.2 did you guys
inherit so I did receive a small
inheritance of $20,000 when I was 17
okay but the rest was all US did you
invest that and that caused this million
dollars to occur
or no so you're not a millionaire
because of inheritance or you are no I
am not okay I'm just I just want to get
from the actual person what the deal is
okay and uh your household income your
best year working and your worst year
working and and you're 30 years old way
to
go yeah we're we're we're thrilled we we
started out we looked at everything
combined we've been married 10 years um
uh our our starting salaries when we
first started working combined was about
130,000 and um now today we're making
about 240 good very good and uh what
what is your
careers um I work part-time I work in
finance um and my husband is an engineer
oh good okay all right and uh your your
what was his GPA or do you
remember he's a smarty his he did have a
4.0 GPA good good well if he's an I hope
so I don't want the bridge to fall right
so there we go right good and so his
degree is in engineering yours is in
finance yes um it's in accounting my
undergrad and then um we both actually
have NBAs so excellent excellent work
yeah so do you think people that are
listening that are 20 and 22 years old
or they're tuning in on YouTube do you
think they can do this like you did
absolutely yes I why do you think the
dream is not
dead what was that why do you think the
American dream is not dead
because I think it's it's capable of
happening through hard work I think that
in the beginning of our marriage and in
our early 20s we hustled really hard we
had lots of side hustles we we spent
three years renovating our our house top
to bottom and turned to $100,000 house
into a $350,000 house and um you know I
think anybody anybody can work hard and
get after it wow that's encouraging
especially hearing from a 30-year-old
cuz most of the youngsters out there
that I talk to and that are commenting
they are looking at these investing
traps and shortcuts and I'm looking at
your portfolio it's largely boring isn't
it it is it's just retirement accounts
and equity in the home and some cash and
college savings there's nothing really
that takes some Prodigy level investing
here you didn't do any day trading or
sports betting or store it all in Gold
nope nope we're in it for the marathon
Race we're in it for the long haul so
just boring and and safe Investments for
us yeah way to go I'm so proud of you
way to go hero George it there's a real
low occurrence when we do these Howers
uh we find almost no crypto wow not even
as we've done them over the last few
years actually never T they may exist
but I have never talked to a crypto
millionaire interesting I thought they
were all over the place they've been
real quiet ever since they took a turn
for the worst ever since it became worth
zero yeah yeah there's that oh there was
one I was a GameStop guy who got who got
rich off the GameStop de I thought we he
made some Ser he called I did talk to
him he was doing that margin thing that
was all over the news for a while he did
he did get rich quick um and got out
just in time but that wasn't crypto that
was playing margins Yep this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Romans 12:2 do
not be conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
that you may prove what is prove what is
that good and acceptable perfect will of
God Albert schwitzer said a good example
has twice the value of good advice this
is a baby steps millionaires theme hour
we are taking calls from real
millionaires the last lie that is told
is that it's impossible to build wealth
in America today because the wealth is
already held by the wealthy amilies and
the only way you become a millionaire is
by
inheritance and that is a statistical
lie here are the the facts are
disturbing things when you believe wrong
things this is a fact having done the
largest study of millionaires in North
America
10,167 of them here's the number
79% inherited
zero 5 % inherited a small amount like 5
or 10,000 one caller of this hour 20,000
but not enough to mathematically cause
them to become a millionaire if your
granny leaves you 5,000 you did have an
inheritance but it doesn't make you a
millionaire unless you live to be 200
years old okay so uh it's not an
inheritance the the third thing is
another 5% received a substantial
inheritance after they were already
millionaires we also had that this hour
the guy with a $3.2 million net worth
said he received $200,000 inheritance
after he was already a millionaire so he
did not become a millionaire because of
inherited money so let me help you with
the numbers 79% Z 5% small amount 5%
after they were already millionaires 79
and5 and 5 is
89 that's N9 out of 10
of America's millionaires are first
generation Rich they are not
millionaires because of inherited
money
simple so anyone that says that is
either lying or just wrong or
both it is simply not true okay that
that's you can't make it any plainer
than that and by the the way that
matches up with 30 years of doing this
and meeting people all over America that
are millionaires I kept running into
them and I ran into very few that
inherited the
money and and almost none I mean it's
less than one out of or just right
around one out of 10 and I don't care if
you inherit money that's fine it's it
doesn't make you a bad person we talked
to a guy earlier in the show today that
inherited a million one from his
grandmother and he was 22 years old
that's wonderful I got no issue that's
fine a moral problem it's just simply
not a fact and when you tell people that
they can't do it and they believe you
you're you're not only wrong you're
infecting other people's hope and you
should be ashamed of yourself stealing
hope that's
awful it especially when you're wrong
hello you're
wrong you're wrong dial that one in for
a
second okay because
I've got the airtight research to prove
it so oh by the way too the five top
careers that came up in the study the
number one career that came up most
often was
engineer number two accountant number
three
teacher number
four uh business executive number five
that attorney
lawyer doctors didn't he make the top
five teachers
did well I I'm a teacher and I don't
make any money and I'm broke listen I I
don't I don't you can whine all you want
to whine it doesn't change the fact that
teachers appeared as the third most
likely group out of 10,000 to become a
millionaire why is that because all five
of those share processes they have to
use a process and become Building Wealth
is a process they're all five process
people Engineers use a process to build
a bridge or it doesn't fall accountants
use a process called Gap generally
accepted accounting principles there's
only one way to do accounting there's
not six you don't get to be creative
about it there's not the Contemporary
version and the traditional version
there's accounting that's it teachers
use a process for teaching it's called a
lesson plan okay business Executives use
a process for managing a project and of
course lawyers use a process in front of
the judge or the judge shuts them down
it's called contemp of Court okay so you
have a process in the law that you use
these are process people they follow a
proven process like a baby steps process
that we use that's why they have a
likelihood of Building Wealth because
they're process people so you can you
could decide to do that even if you're
an artist even if you're not a processed
person by the way artists don't show up
anywhere on any of it and it's not
because you're dumb or something like
that but you you just make up your own
rules that's part of the beauty of art
trying to live free you so but you when
it comes to your money you better be a
process person regardless of what your
career field is Kelly is in Kansas City
Kelly what's your net
worth 3.9 million Dave way to go give me
a little breakdown on that by category
okay Investments are at uh 2.8 million
which is retirement roths got it mutual
funds uh house and cars is um
600 and about 500 in cash and CDs okay
very cool how old are you
59 cool and how much of this 3.9 did you
inherit we did inherit um after our
first million but we did inherit 250,000
after you were already millionaires okay
good fits what I was just talking about
all right and your income range best
year to worst
year uh straight out of college we both
earned
60,000 and our best year so far is about
250 cool what do you all do for a living
what's your careers
I'm a special education teacher M and my
husband is a manufacturer sales rep
MH okay High number of salespeople show
up in this study too okay and your well
he also has the accounting um degree so
you hit both in the top five okay all
right teacher and accountant yeah both
of you okay G
GPA uh his was a 3.4 mine was
3.9 all right good he married up good
for
him you think this can still be done can
somebody still be at 59 years old and
have a 4 million net worth absolutely
what should they do
absolutely um several things we did um
they have to be on the same page
together husband and wife we've been
together for 37 years um my husband
wanted this to be a goal so he asked me
to read your book and about 15 years ago
we read The Total Money Makeover wow we
all on the same page together
um uh staying with your
budget uh saving early and often started
saving um the first year I started
teaching very good I like that a lot
what would what advice would you give to
the 25y old version of
you start early and more often what's
the biggest mistake you all ever made
with
money
I think it was a real estate um
agreement my husband went into that was
probably our biggest like an investment
deal went bad yeah yeah how much did you
lose I think it was about 100K okay cool
yeah that's a bad one yeah left a left a
mark yeah okay wow and yet here you sit
at 60 years old and you you read The
Total Money Makeover at
45 and or 44 and
uh with a $5 million or $4 million net
worth and so Wow way to go hero how's it
feel thank you oh it's it's amazing um
the first thing that you do when you pay
off that house when you're in your 40s
and it's like a weight went off your
back and um you're very comfortable yeah
and then it's easy to build after that
isn't it it's so easy after that yeah
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income we've said it for 30
years here and she's just telling you
again folks way to go Kelly so proud of
you George they're everywhere from 30 60
a million to 4 million and it's all real
boring but also very encouraging yeah
yeah yeah nothing flashy there's no
Fancy no fancy in there makes me feel
like even someone as dumb as me could do
it Dave and I and I did it you already
did yeah you are very similar stories
way to go I love it that puts us our the
the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus
[Music]
la